tant les gens le titre franchement oui
mat je kiffe ce titre de niche que
lesdits directs indirects et chaud tu es
bon match alors je vais te dire cgl
hanche et l'oreille universel dit ouais
l'oreille accusé mois français à
recevoir de personne et surtout pas de
vous d'accord 1 marie antoinette la
voilà c'est mon modèle avez raison alors
j'ai l'oreille absolue comme la vodka et
je te lis le titre et où il ya l'album
qui va sortir bientôt
yes nouvel album pyramide ça y est
attendu new york comme un titre sur la
tournée sur l'album sort l'album je suis
à je crois c'est 13 13 titres près ce
titre est une autre et d une autre
version avec 3,4 de plus comment comment
choisi le single parce que c'est vrai
que la canton quand tu reviens comme ça
tu vois là tu t'es lis ici si celui-là
le csu et le bon alors déjà ya des
évidences en studio quand tout le monde
réagit après des titres c'est plus des
partis pris tu sais que ça va plaire à
plus à ma génération d'autres un peu
plus âgés d'autres un peu plus même si
tu aimes ce qu'on appelle un peu plus
large celui là je pense que c'est c'est
c'était une évidence pour tout le monde
dès qu'on l'a des cons entendu pour la
première fois je pense que c'était en
tout cas le sucre qui était le plus
représentatif de la d'esprit de l'album
de la musicalité de l'album c'est en
tout cas c'est un c'est un tube et inand
à défaut sur les réseaux sociaux de dix
mois
protat été cette pause déjà parce que je
venais de sortir d'une d'une grosse
tournée je voulais un peu redescendre
après tout ça ça va quand même quinze
ans que j'ai enchaîné les albums et les
tournées étaient fatigués des albums les
tournées je pourrais j'étais arrivé à un
peu à saturation
j'ai un jeu j'avais envie de rester chez
moi un peu j'avais j'en avais dépens de
partir tout le temps sur les routes
partir tout le temps il y avait eu des
trucs violons sur les réseaux pas du
tout c'est un produit toit du tout c'est
justement envie d'être un peu tranquille
ouais non c'est ça en fait j'avais juste
besoin de profiter un peu de mes proches
de ma famille de me retrouver un peu de
profiter un peu de la vie de voilà tout
simplement mais c'est beaucoup de
pression c'est un métier bien sûr qu'on
a plein davantage dans ces magnifiques
je suis un privilégié mais c'est aussi à
plein de choses à côté ou fait beaucoup
de sacrifices on met beaucoup de côté
notre vie privée
on est tout le temps observé comment pas
les critiques et voilà que ce soit en
arkansas et sur les réseaux sociaux pour
tous aujourd'hui à la sortie du titre ou
pas la regarder où j'étais sûr en promo
un peu toute la journée donc j'ai vu
j'ai vu les réactions raging j'ai vu que
le titre était premier donc pas là c'est
super rassurant
et est ce que ce qu'on sait que tu es
beaucoup à los angeles tu vas rester un
petit peu en france là à wil à ça ça
s'arrête à cette année tête avec 90 % du
temps ici et puis les vacances là bas
bon bah très bien rodée on est content
tu as ta maman tu appelles toujours kiki
[Rires]
et je suis le dernier de la famille doit
donc c'est toujours moi elle veut pas
comprendre que le dernier il peut avoir
trente trois ans et moi c'est carrément
qui doit manger savoir quand même
content avec ta meuf et où c'est qui qui
a ouai mais heureusement elle comprend
pas
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]